let's bring in chad wolfe you know chad
former acting dhs secretary
heritage foundation visiting fellow at
this point uh hey chad
uh you've seen this before but not at
this numbers what
changed well i
what i can tell you is we we have a
full-blown crisis on our southwest
border at the moment i would say what
has changed is the messaging out of the
administration back in 2019
under president trump we had messaging
as
don't come because you will not be let
into the country we know that the vast
majority of these folks do not
qualify for asylum but unfortunately
today we have a different set of
messaging and a different set of
policies in place
which are encouraging they are the pull
factors that we see today which is
encouraging this crisis
all right let's uh hear from the
president and get your reaction on the
other side listen to this this is joe
biden
the idea that joe biden said come
because i i heard the other day that
they're coming because they know i'm a
nice guy and i won't give you
this yeah well here's the deal they're
not
do you have to say quite clearly don't
come yes
i can say quite clearly don't come and
we're in the process of getting set up
don't leave your town our city or
community
chad you just heard griff jenkins say he
interviewed that migrant and
the man said that's not the message
being spread down here
it's being spread to come
yeah absolutely i think you had a dhs
official secretary talk about
from the white house podium saying you
can come but don't come now so their
messaging is certainly not consistent
but at the end of the day
these illegal migrants don't listen to
government officials they listen to
other
illegals who have gotten into the u.s
that call them and tell them that they
are here
they are staying in the u.s they are not
being deported or removed back to their
home countries
that's how they vote that's that's what
they're listening to so as long as they
see other individuals
coming into the u.s being catch and
released
into the u.s and staying here you're
going to continue to see this surge
but chad wasn't this a part of the plan
all along here's joe biden
talking about this back in 2019 saying
that we need more immigrants here
maybe 2 million take a look
we could afford to take in a heartbeat
another 2 million people the idea that a
country of 330 million people
cannot absorb people who are in
desperate need
and who are justifiably fleeing
oppression
is absolutely bizarre absolutely bizarre
i would also move to increase the total
number of immigrants able to come to the
united states
chad what's your reaction well what i
would say is the us
is certainly the most welcoming country
in the world when we talk about refugees
and asylees but
obviously the facts also uh dispute a
lot of what was just said there 90
of these individuals do not qualify for
asylum are not being persecuted under
the asylum laws that we have today
and so what that means is we have to
remove them so if they come into the us
we do the catch and release we then have
to go out and find them and remove them
and that is an
inhumane policy and an inhumane message
that we want to send to folks
come up spend your life's worth trying
to get into the u.s stay here for a year
and then be removed back to your home
country
it's not the right message and it's
fueling this crisis is it right to jump
the line over everybody else doing
things right paying the fees
filling out the forms going by our laws
meanwhile guess what it's your fault
that according to the new dhs secretary
he blames the trump administration
quote the prior administration
completely dismantled the asylum system
we have to rebuild the entire system
including the policies
procedures required to administer the
asylum laws that congress
passed long ago the prior administration
tore down the lawful pathways
that have been developed for children to
come to the united states in a safe
efficient orderly way the previous
administration also cut foreign aid
funding to the northern triangle
do you want to deal with those facts as
they see them
absolutely there's a couple points being
made there one we gave them
one of the most secure borders that
we've ever had we gave them a network of
policies that allowed them to quickly
remove
individuals to seek protection
closer to their home countries in the
northern triangle
and provide them the asylum system
through mpp
all of it was working we briefed the
transition team uh we gave them
the results of if they decided to remove
these policies what would happen so the
fact that they're not prepared today
is really quite unconscionable when we
talk about asylum systems saying that
the trump administration tore that down
nothing could be further from the truth
we hired over 500 asylum officers
we addressed the asylum backlog and
during the four years of the trump
administration dhs and doj
gave more people asylum than the last
four years of the obama administration
so this claim that we tore down a system
is simply not backed up by the facts and
you restored their aid too right
you restored the aid to the triangle
countries when they were responsive to
your request
to reign in their population
absolutely so what we did there was we
held them accountable we wanted to see
results before we provided them
millions and millions of dollars in
foreign aid and that's how it should be
we worked with them we signed over a
dozen different agreements with the
northern triangle
and had some of the best cooperation and
we restored that foreign assistance when
we saw
those results and that's how it should
be chad is that money that american
money is it going to these triangle
countries so that they can
fix the problems there where they do
have oppression where they do have
persecution
where they do have these folks who want
to come over here and
claim asylum because they're dangerous
areas where they live
are they using that money to fix that
problem
yeah so they're using uh some of our
foreign assistance funding to not only
deal with sort of the rule of law and
corruption issues in the northern
triangle
but also for border security for that
illegal or irregular migration flows and
so we need them to do both we need them
to address the root causes of that
migration
but also on the security front and
that's what we were pushing at the end
of the trump administration
and again we saw some really great
results we did not have any migrant
caravans
in 2020 under these agreements uh and we
did not have these surges that you see
today
i believe as chad thank you so much for
being on with us
all right thank you you're welcome